um
yes
like
okay
oh
oh yeah
okay
good morning everyone
as of 10 a.m there were a little
under 5 500 votes left to be counted in
gwinnett
floyd cherokee and cobb county
in addition there are 8 890
military ballots outstanding that will
be counted if they were
returned by the close of business today
right now georgia remains too close to
call
i have approximately 5 million votes
cast
will have a margin of a few thousand
the focus for our office and for the
county election officials
for now remains on making sure that
every
legal vote is counted and recorded
accurately
as we are closing in on a final count we
can begin to look
toward our next steps with a margin that
small
there will be a recount in georgia
interest in our election obviously goes
far beyond
georgia's borders the final tally in
georgia
at this point has huge implications for
the entire country
the stakes are high and emotions are
high
on all sides we will not let those
debates
distract us from our work we will get it
right
and we'll defend the integrity of our
elections in some states
there are complaints about monitors not
being allowed
to watch the count in georgia
this process is and will remain open and
transparent to monitors
if any member of the public raises
legitimate concerns
we'll investigate those we are committed
to doing anything and everything
to maintaining trust in our elections
process
for every georgian regardless of
partisan preference
thank you very much mr secretary will
you take any questions
hi guys we're going to go over the
details again
of where we stand on the vote counts
there have been some changes overnight
and even
changes from the time we walked from the
front door of the office to the front of
the cameras today i'm gabriel sterling
the statewide voting system
implementation manager
good to see everybody here again this
morning as we close in on a final tally
uh the secretary just announced a
particular set of numbers that actually
went down from the time we walked from
the door to here
so our new total that we are aware of
right now is 4169
and they are in a handful of counties
i'll go over those now um
in cherokee county there were 150
ballots that they
did not upload so i had to rescan
they're uploading those today
um there's 75 now in cobb
there's 444 in floyd
there's approximately 3 500 in gwinnett
as we went through the reconciliation
process
of what they had already reported versus
what they had left to newly scan
and i think that's it a couple of things
lawrence county the 1769 votes we had
yesterday we were basing those on the
absentee ballot differences
and when they looked and did their
reconciliation process on it
they discovered that they had
accidentally uh
uploaded those into their election day
totals their totals will not change
but the vote type will change when they
make that change today
so outside of that we don't have any
other numbers that we are aware of but
again i want to remind everybody
we have ballot curing processes through
today for absentee ballots
a verification process for provisional
ballots
and we can still get any military or
yuakawa ballots in
by close of business today if they were
postmarked on tuesday election day
so there are still an unknowable amount
of ballots that would be available
to be counted at some point they are in
the hands of
the um elections officials now other
than maybe the military and you kava
ones
and i can assure you that there are
teams of 20-somethings around the state
who are republicans and democrats
finding those people with those absentee
ballots to cure
and they're going through that process
in county by county and ones and twos
and just a preemptive question i know
it's going to come up are we seeing any
widespread fraud are we seeing anything
that makes us question the outcome of
the election
we're not seeing widespread
irregularities we're not seeing anything
widespread
we're investigating any credible
accusation with any real evidence behind
it but let me tell you one thing
when you have a narrow margin little
small
things can make a difference so
everything's gonna have to be
investigated to protect the integrity of
the vote
our office intends to do that and like i
said
you get a wide margin it doesn't matter
as much narrow margin it does
we are literally looking at a margin of
less than you know a large high school
so we understand that in this state the
county officials are aware of that our
investigators are aware of that
so it's an important thing to protect
the integrity of this election
from all sides without saying any
questions you'll have yes um
with the margin we have and with the
certainty of a recount are we gonna know
who won the presidency in georgia by the
end of november
with the timeline we have laid out uh
essentially
we let's go to the timeline again so we
we should be able to know by the end of
november because remember we have a
mid-december deadline in order to see
the left doors
so the one thing that is always going to
be an unknowable unknown is lawsuits
that can affect
what we have to do we are a rule a
country in a nation of laws
so if a judge tells us to do something a
certain way we're going to have to do
that
let the legal process work its way out
but given the laws we have now in the
situation
and and posture that we are in today
today is the last day to cure
all those absentee ballots uh get the
military overseas in
and then i'm gonna verify the
provisionals so that gets you your outer
bound of these
then you have the situation where the
counties need
to certify their election so they take
that they give us a bunch of paperwork
they do the reconciliations they make
sure they have everything right
and trust me these people work very hard
at it again they are all very tired but
we work with them very diligently to get
that in as fast as we can
because state certification can come
only after we do
our risk limiting audit and that is
going to be the first time the state's
doing it it was part of hb 316
secretary raffensberger's election
reform law so that happens
and then we're going to have the state
certification now the outward bound of
that is november
20th our hope and intent working with
the counties is to move that
earlier and at that point whomever comes
in second whether it be president trump
or
vice president biden either one of them
who's ever in second place
can request that recount if it's within
half a percent but you can't do a recap
until
after the audit and after the
certification
within most interpretations of the law
right now you cannot do it
a recount cannot be requested until the
election is certified that would take
about five days
we have no way of knowing right now
we've never done a statewide recount
with a brand new system
so we are hoping it would be a week but
we have no way of actually knowing that
at this point
that the um count is secure and accurate
that chain of custody is preserved
that poll workers are doing their job
properly
what can you say about how co-workers
and election officials and election
directors
are doing to make sure that everything
is fair and accurate
we have 159 election directors thousands
of poll workers election workers
um hundreds of volunteers on judication
panels
they are all in there as the secretary
noted this is a public process
you can watch everything that's
happening they have paperwork
there's certifications there's
reconciliations there's paperwork on top
of paperwork in many cases so we know
how many ballots there are
one of the things we know from the from
wednesday night on we knew the basic
amount of ballots that were there
um with the slight moving target of the
military coming in
the absentee ballots being cured and the
potential provisionals because those are
all essentially unknowable at the end of
the night on tuesday people ask the
question why can't you know exactly how
many you have
because it's impossible because there's
the law allows for these things to be
done
to protect the ballots of those who we
really want to make sure get to vote
so in general and specifically this
office
has worked very hard through the reforms
in hb316
which also allow for notifications to be
immediately sent out
for ballots that are received towards
the end of the process
that need to be cured um people talk
about it's a three-day cure
process on this and if that's not the
case what it is if you send in your
ballot early you can have a month-long
cure process if it comes in that way
that's why i was always encouraging
people to do that
as early as they possibly could but our
office and the counties have many many
safeguards many many guardrails built up
over many years
to ensure the integrity of the vote yes
ma'am
well i'm not going to talk about an
ongoing investigation at this time
um but harvesting votes for a recount be
difficult because you already have the
outward edge of what recount already
showed
or the original account already showed
yes sir
i'm not going to try to get into the
president's actual mindset on that
because there are
there are republicans who are involved
there are democrats involved at
different levels sort of a shared
service delivery model
there are republican election directors
there are democrat election directors
obviously secretary raffensbury is a
republican i'm a republican
i don't make any bones about anybody who
knows me and i've suddenly had a lot of
people look at my twitter feed and my
linkedin it's pretty obvious
so in general we have people who have
partisan
beliefs but the job of elections
directors in this office is to count
every legal vote follow the law and
assure that every legal vote is counted
and the
will and attention to the voters is met
yes
we have no way of knowing it possibly
could the one thing people ask me with
this 8 900 potential military ballots
coming in
they asked me how many i said i don't
know i'll tell you one thing it'll be
more than zero it'll be less than 8 900.
yes
as i said we can't know because they're
in the post office it's like i said
it'll be more than zero and less than 8
900.
yes sir
i'm not aware of any at this time yes
um here's the situation the risk living
on it has to be done before there is a
recount anyway so now that shouldn't
really have an effect on that
and to clear up one thing i want to make
sure everybody understands
the law in georgia is that the
candidates must be within a half a
percent of each other
in order to have a recount so i'm
hearing speculation potentially about a
recount in the united states senate race
involving um
mr ossoff and senator perdue uh
that margin is so wide with the bail
availables out right now
there's no way the two of them could
probably get to the half point each
potentially they could but it's very
unlikely so it
would probably only be for president
what would that look like
you're gonna let me get into my fun geek
time now to go over the seb rules that
we outlined when we passed this law
this is the way it's going to work as i
mentioned to y'all
yesterday the secretary directed that we
procure in the original procurement
uh the high-speed iccs which are the
high-capacity high-speed scanners
that will be used at the central offices
for this recount now how we're going to
do that
is we're going to take a deck of ballots
we're going to have this hand counted
going by what is written on the the
human readable portion of that
by the readable portion of that we'll
tally those and we'll get a count write
it down we will then run those through
the scanners
and they ought to match and once we
validate that that scanner is scanning
properly
we will then be scanning every single
ballot again
on the central scanners like i said
we're making estimates of time we don't
know
um like i said i hope i'm hoping there's
some time when our elections workers
will get some sleep
because you know it's it's going to be a
high stress thing because again the eyes
the world are upon them but
that's the essential outline of how it
works there's other details of how you
how you handle but that's the basics
we are aware that there's a couple of
places we've heard about potentially
happening
we don't know exactly why yet it could
be a simple thing as on the pole pad it
searches first name last name and date
of birth
so they could have been looking at the
wrong person not realizing it
immediately because like i said the
poll workers are human um so and human
beings are involved with all this level
so there can be errors in those but we
are obviously looking into it with the
vendor to see if there's anything
that can be discovered about why that
might have happened
anybody else yes sir you again
[Music]
i do not right now we're trying to get
that but again we're trying to leave the
elections official officials and
directors to their actual accounts yes
here's the reality i think the ones the
battle is talking about here today will
probably be done today
to tonight but remember close of
business
means their stuff's coming in to close
the business so we don't know the volume
of those we don't know where they're
going to be
there somebody could have left you know
they could be exhausted and have to get
the mail you know
after that so there's no way of knowing
exactly i anticipate we should get
closer to final
final on saturday um people going
through it they
their damage balance make sure they get
cop reconciled properly and cop
and duplicated properly and scan so
it'll be
probably this we can be and normally it
wouldn't matter if the
if the difference wasn't 1 000 votes yes
sir
no so no conversation you mentioned uh
the closest is that we're hearing a lot
about the accounting of ballots in
georgia and the speed we're
counting that is this accounting problem
or is this simply a matter of the margin
the fact that we have so many
so close of elections it's it's there's
two things in here
i know many people seem to forget we
were still in the middle of pandemic
during a lot of this so
georgia historically has about five
percent absentees this time it's like
close to a third
and that's um about 1.25 million ballots
that we're having to count so
they've never had to handle this bond
with paper before and they're having to
handle the volume of paper and the
handling
and all of the valid custody rules
around those things
there's extra things we've never had to
deal with before i think we're going to
make t-shirts that says i survived the
2020 election where we have a pandemic
merging elections hurricane
and then recounts so that's going to be
our plan but it's a mainly question of
the volume
we can't know what's happening in all
159 counties we only
stay with more counties and this is
texas so we
we anticipate most will be and the
problem is they can find a couple things
within the reconciliations that's why
you have certification to get to that
final number
and we're trying to get the counties to
certify as fast as they can so we can
move to our risk limiting audit so that
we can certify as fast as we can and
move to what looks like a
likely recount called by either one of
the second place candidates
county they wanted to have one more
adjudication server and that was
supplied
yes
about seventeen thousand about seventeen
thousand have already and those
seventeen thousand already included in
the counts we have
yes sir i'll come back
you just want to see me get that
computer back out again all right give
me a second
correct except for there are 400
election day ballots that are included
in the gwinnett totals
so that's the only other difference in
this all right so let's start from the
top
cherokee 150 cobb 75
floyd 444 gwinnett approximately 3 500
and for a total of 4169
absentee except for the 400 of the ones
in gwinnett that that were part of the
um
early voting that they had to rescan all
right
anybody anything else all right
not that i'm aware of i mean and let me
i want to put some clarity to this
because we have some more information
about it it wasn't a water main break
what it was was uh during the offseason
and during the pandemic they shut off
the toilets
and they were turned off and there was a
leak they got around one of the edges of
the shutoff valves
and over time over time over time and
it's just kind of like
we said we got hit with a hurricane i
mean i'm going to add a water leak to
the um t-shirt i think on the surviving
election 2020. all right anything else
all right thank you
i really couldn't say it right now
whatever we because there's different
levels of investigation so you do the
phone calls to make sure there's any
credibility then you're like yes this
credibility then the real investigation
so
i'm not going to parse through that
obviously we're getting stuff and you
know
if you look on facebook and twitter
obviously there's millions of problems
all across the country
if somebody has a credible um complaint
and they have some kind of evidence or
some kind of trail to an evidence
they can probably they can give our
office a call and if they're in another
state give your state office a call
because we want to make sure we protect
the integrity of the ballot because
that's the way
you're going to build faith back in the
system that the outcome of the election
is correct
thanks a lot y'all
i